my name is Ceylon Perec I'm an associate
professor of Orthopedic Surgery at the
4th Phoenix ok glass record a video back
in October I obtained my first pair of
Google glass and played around with it
for a little bit in the operating room
but then in January when I went to India
for our charitable work that's when I
started to realize the true power of
wearable technologies in healthcare when
we went to India we met with press and
at the time in front of the press I
happen to take out the Google glass the
media saw the Google glass and said wow
we want to see that in action and so we
start trying how we could do a live
broadcast of the Google glass surgery
from India got broadcast throughout the
world 15 to 20 thousand people tuned in
to the surgery it started to allow me to
realize that this could really be a tool
versus just a cool gadget that that's
nice to where I based technology is
really going to change healthcare in a
number of different ways being able to
pull up cat-scans MRIs x-rays patients
medical records so instantaneously that
physician has access to the patient's
health information imagine that your
surgeon is in the operating room and in
the middle of the case comes up with
either a difficulty or anomaly he could
potentially bring in any surgeon who's
an expert in that material or that
expert surgeon can put his hands over a
mat that he has in his office and now
his hands can be seen through Google
glass so that the expert surgeon can
really participate in the operating room
five years down the line ten years down
the line I think all of us will have
wearable technologies in some form on us
this is all going to change how
healthcare is delivered over the next
century
[Music]